going back to taxi drivers though have
you ever had any weird or like
bad taxi experiences worldwide oh yeah
definitely in europe i've had some
pretty europe shitty taxis wait where
where in europe
france oh was it taxi taxi
and uber the worst uber writer i ever
had was in france i don't know why all
the weird taxi experiences i've had have
been in la
like really yeah yeah yeah i've i've
only had like taxis or ubers
ubers ubers right yeah i like when they
talk to you in l.a it's nice no ubertax
uber's in la i've always had like a
pleasant time it's it's it's
it's weird because i've i've for like
the most part
i've had very pleasant experiences with
uber in l.a yeah but
there's this one there's sometimes i get
a really odd experience
and it's it's okay so the oddest
experience i've ever had with uber in
l.a it was uh during ax time
and we were all we were it was me and uh
two other friends and all we were doing
was we wanted to take a taxi
to the convention hall and this was late
at night by the way so it was uh
it wasn't like the daytime it was like
let's say 7
8 p.m so it's kind of night time the
time the sun was down so we get
we we call this uber and this like
this car just rocks up and it's like a
[ __ ] decrepit
broken car like i was just like how how
the [ __ ]
has like how the [ __ ] has this passed
like uber standards i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure that i'm pretty sure
they're like a dead body had been there
you know what i mean so we use so we
were like oh
this this is this is the uber oh okay so
we we were like whatever it's like a
5-10 minute journey anyway it doesn't
really matter that much so we're getting
this taxi driver and immediately he
opens his mouth and
you can kind of feel that he's he's not
all there in the head yeah
yeah he has a yeah he has a screw loose
right right why
what was he saying so i mean so at the
beginning he was talking about
guys i gotta i gotta ask you a favor can
you can you please give me five stars
for my journey
all i'm asking for is one five star i
just want a five star okay
i just keep i keep getting one stars and
i don't know why
i don't know why i don't know why he's
like that he's like the one like kid
yeah yeah yeah
then i'm like okay okay that's an
aggressive way to ask for a positive
review but
sure sure that is not how you get fired
so so sure we'll give you a five star so
he starts
starts driving to this convention hall
right yeah and
he puts it in the gps we go to the uh la
convention center
and then it says to go it says to go on
a turning right
yeah and then it says please turn right
doesn't listen he goes forward
right right and then he goes and then so
it's fine the gps corrects itself and
goes please turn right at the next
turning
ignores that one keeps going forward and
in in between
him ignoring this gps and getting
further and further away from the
convention center
because i was like on google maps
because i was like what what the [ __ ] is
the taxi driver doing
and he he goes and he he keeps talking
about this [ __ ] five star and one
star ran right right and he he goes
if i get another bad review i'm gonna
lose it man
i'm gonna lose it you're like hovering
he keeps saying that i'm just i'm just
like making eyes because i'm sitting in
the front
and my teammates sitting in the back and
i'm just trying to make eyes to be like
oh you're in the passenger yeah yeah
yeah so i'm just like yo if
he pulls the gun like you you got my
back right like if something happens she
got my back
and so the third time the gps tells to
turn right
and he he misses it again and i'm just
like
[ __ ] man some something's gone wrong we
need to get out of this taxi right now
i'd rather get another uber than get
further and further away from safety
which is the convention center
and stay one second longer than this
taxi so we're like don't worry man um
we're close enough to the convention
center we can just we can just stop here
we can just stop here and he goes are
you sure
you sure and so we're just like yeah
yeah please please stop
please just stop and so we get out of
the taxi and he
and um as i'm getting out he leans over
and he goes you're gonna give me your
five star right here we go
yeah yeah yeah yeah five star five star
five star you promised
five star yeah five star and we're like
yeah yeah yeah don't worry we'll give
you a five star
all right looking forward to that five
star drives off
instant one i was gonna say i hope you
can vote
yeah i hope it was a one star because
people like like i don't care how nice
you are you shouldn't [ __ ] be an uber
driver if you're pulling [ __ ] like that
that's not that's the equivalent of like
getting a pizza delivered and the guy
being like
20 dollar tip right you got to give me
at least a 20 dollar too ten dollars no
no 20.
but i i could very much see during that
experience why people gave him one stars
because
i mean i kind of feared for my safety at
one point during that taxi ride i mean
it's like it's not even a matter of him
just like ranting about like i'm gonna
kill a [ __ ] if i get another one
because yeah yeah
the fact that he wasn't even going the
right way he wasn't going the right way
and like i was like okay at the
beginning when he asked for the
lifestyle like whatever it's the [ __ ]
review i didn't give a [ __ ]
but when he was like i'm gonna lose him
man
i was just like oh [ __ ] man this is
that's [ __ ] terrifying
especially la you don't know what the
[ __ ] gonna happen yeah exactly